[Music]
so this week we've got trained to stink
town oh [ __ ]
fear the reaper fear the reaper and
mistake and rescue - - like they rescued
the terrorists instead of the soldier I
just said cheesy because your shirts
yellow and you look cheesy Gillette you
assaulted her and the pride of her job
oh yeah that's the same color of [ __ ]
Cheez Whiz and the background no all
right so anyway for our first story
there's this train that has [ __ ] for
cargo sitting what kind of [ __ ] you
mention for real
you humans pcs is the worst fishies what
about dog feces oh I'll smell dog feces
all day smell dog versus human [ __ ] yeah
tired dog feces - upper lip okay so
let's say that's what they did right
yeah as punishment and they're like you
want dog [ __ ] or human [ __ ] my human is
my [ __ ] I'll take your [ __ ] my shits
like a cigar smell nothing I think I
just saw the picture and the pic it
looks like a cigar but retinas so it's
an omelet cigar feels like much it
smells like a Swisher is setlists like
dried fruit yeah it smells better than
it tastes yeah I like smelling American
spirits when they're not lit hmm huh why
well because I never smoke so when I
smell cigarettes before I was like oh it
smells like dried fruit hmm I love the
way tobacco smells before it's lit all
right well here we're talking about a
poop train though okay in Alabama and
they're saying that this poop doesn't
even belong to the people of Alabama it
belongs to people in New York give it
back to them
the traded motion listen it's just going
through it's sitting there why the [ __ ]
is on the train and the train just John
that's because all the poopoo gets
treated at somewhere and then they pick
up the poo poo and then they move it and
they use it as a fertilizer well so
making up your own stories for the lie
sir yeah so apparently the wastewater
treatment plant that's not my own story
that's how I know about that but a lot
of [ __ ] [ __ ] and poopoo get flushed
down the toilet and then you collect
that [ __ ] and I know the difference okay
this guy sir explain it to her
come on now okay [ __ ] is like oh [ __ ]
that's the worst kind of [ __ ] and bloopo
is like it's kind of cute solid solid
solid in diarrhea so you know where you
know where your poop goes when you flush
yeah underneath the [ __ ] sewage pipes
yeah but the tap water that we use is
also easy yep yeah it's treated right so
how do they treat it is they have a
filter for all that [ __ ] and then they
collect all that [ __ ] let that
[ __ ] marinate and then they
truckload that [ __ ] to an area and they
let that [ __ ] marinate treat that bottle
[ __ ] and then they sell off that [ __ ]
that's I'm only gonna stay to drinking
soda
you know our [ __ ] did you know that they
sell our [ __ ] I really want that I
mentioned this before but just somebody
figure out a way to desalinate water
like cheaper it's just so [ __ ]
expensive to take like salt out of water
because there's so much salt in it yeah
so now it's like if we take that then we
could I don't know this is my mind
thinking right now
if you could take all that [ __ ] right
and then we [ __ ] lower the [ __ ]
water levels of the ocean I don't know
how much we have to do style and ice but
that'd be amazing if our freshwater
source was just from the ocean and if
they could do it instantly so you can
just kill schools of fish at a time you
know we already have too much water all
in ocean yeah it's already rising up
because like the ice caps are melting
anyways so it's all good
polar bears yeah so several wastewater
treatment plants from New York and New
Jersey struck a deal to send their poop
to this landfill in Adamsville Alabama
but apparently the train the local rail
yard didn't have proper zoning and so
they stopped taking it there they ended
up taking their operation to Parrish
Alabama and we're stuck to February I
was like it's a shitty place since
February that's where these poop cars
have been it couldn't make them
nice-looking now just thinking up the
whole [ __ ] town wow that's a lot of
[ __ ] yeah
and that's like condensed Dookie -
that's sewer Duke biosolids
okay they make it into solid you know
what else smells like [ __ ] [ __ ]
Chinatown oh yeah yeah Chinatown smells
like [ __ ] seafood cigarettes and
bumpy you know to me like why I don't
know but it smells bad every time I
Drive through that you guys been -
what's it called is it what we're trying
to located in New York boy Flushing's is
I should know they're [ __ ] Chinatown
smells like [ __ ]
New York's ozzie do like most like
Dookie it smells like art at odd times
10 no that's horrible pretty bad because
I was a kid my parents used to go to
Chinatown all the time and I would just
sleep in the back seat in the car and I
always knew we were in Chinatown just
from the smell
dan that's like dogs that know that
there's a dog park coming up yeah I'm
just sleeping and then we roll up and
I'm just like I think we're about to
park and I would look up on my yup it's
the place that smells like [ __ ] again
and a hint of [ __ ] incense or like
mothballs oh yeah there's a hint there's
a yeah some kind of herb like oh dr
scorpion or some [ __ ] is in there
chinatown though they got some dope-ass
plants though for cheap that's true
you could get a ready or slider but the
[ __ ] mom dude this
say every video no but listen to me how
the [ __ ] am I like a mom when I [ __ ]
slaying it up though I just add a little
pizzazz to it yeah I'm saying I like
Chinatown they got some dope though
that's I said you're like Imam I try to
cover it up they got a flyswatter spot
for a dollar yeah yeah right now what
I'm cool lesbian yeah real talk right
now what I'm trying to do though is I'm
trying to reproduce sucking and so I can
grow some new ones what does that mean
so basically you take a piece of the
succulent you twist it off and that
piece can actually grow another sucker
so it takes it takes about a month so
technically what you can do is a
horticulturist your [ __ ] to culture I
do the same thing I have more plants
than David yeah yeah but you don't sound
like a [ __ ] what is it a quarter
intellectual person oh yeah yeah yeah
somebody who knows their [ __ ] oh yeah
yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah I did
succulent arrangement with Jessica
Jessica judge you I accept you we have
two big bowls and we put all of our
succulents there and we did arrangements
that [ __ ] looks like a [ __ ] succulent
tower it's awesome yeah it's like a
terrarium yeah educate you yeah but I
started propagating my plants because
what happened was you know when it got
windy and rainy my [ __ ] knocked over on
that then it looked like they were dead
because they're all smashed up they
don't that really multiply I saw like I
grabbed it I [ __ ] threw it over the
thing and then I what thing where did
you throw I have a balcony and there's a
bunch of plants you just threw it
outside so I just threw it out into the
into the plant area that I looked up
like how succulents can whatever whatnot
and they said like I shouldn't have
thrown it away I can actually just pluck
those leaves off and we propagate it and
they cut it and then just planning to
get any would've been fine I didn't know
that [ __ ] so you went downstairs it's
like it's like in this forested area I
can't even get you know what else does
that though weed seeds my neighbors
through weed seeds over at my mom's
garden that's a scene we all tree yeah
he's gonna grow
Oh 24 the surprise part for a second
excuse you know what happened I [ __ ]
plant a seed and it grew what the [ __ ] I
got the tape I'll tape my own mouth yeah
there's a lot of plants that you can
clone pretty easily yeah yeah so the
poop train here the people of the town
are really men and they've been saying
like isn't this a health issue like we
can't even go outside it just stink so
bad it's just a health issue to smell
some bad [ __ ] I don't think so public
health issue
there's tons of [ __ ] there might be
bacterial articles no one's gotten sick
from it it's not considered a public
health issue but the town is still
optimistic because about half of the
containers have already been removed and
New York City announced that it will
stop sending its waste to that landfill
so right next story there was this man
that was put in the hospital after
eating a Carolina Reaper oh [ __ ] pepper
in the world yeah I thought he ate a
snake or something I heard on my skull
no no it's it was crazy so 1.5 million
on the Scoville heat scale what was the
two hottest ones that we ate we ate
Carolina Reaper and then a ghost pepper
right so Carolina Reaper is I think
there's a smaller one that goes after
the ghost pepper looks like you're like
a dried up tomato all right yeah the
ghost pepper boy or vice versa one of
them is a smaller one the other one
looks like a dried up tomato
yeah they look really similar they look
really similar but they're both really
hardcore but the Carolina Reaper I
specifically remember my hand touched it
[ __ ] ate it like this burn me up so
[ __ ] hard that I had to take a nap
during my nap I went to sleep like this
on the couch and when I woke up the
whole half of my face was burnt because
I touched the Carolina Reaper with my
hand yeah you know back in the day
before like all this this foodie scene
happen there was this like taco joint
out in gardena they used to sell tacos
with ghost pepper
in salsa gold and it was like you had to
sign a release form or you ate it and it
was like a gimmick like it was like a
like a fun thing - yeah it was like you
try it was like 2 bucks - for the taco
so it wasn't expensive for the challenge
I literally nibbled on it yeah threw up
it was so [ __ ] spicy you didn't get
your picture not yeah but my friend you
can't you can't throw up either like you
have to finish you can be cool yeah you
know how hot that [ __ ] is though we ate
a fresh jalapeno after and now she just
tasted like a bell pepper and it was
actually enjoyable to eat a jalapeno
Carolina Reapers 400 times hotter than a
jalapeno I just can't do that [ __ ]
anymore because my my stomach can't or
my intestinal tract can it just passes
the oil through it it doesn't digest it
so even though certain people who don't
have that problem like instantly when I
have hot food is gonna come out I didn't
have that when I was younger
ya know if I eat something spicy I'm
[ __ ] yep 100% yeah so this man this
34 year old unidentified man cuz he died
they're just keeping him anonymous not
at his fingertips on because he doesn't
want to get made fun of like you little
[ __ ] I [ __ ] eat that [ __ ] on a daily
well I wouldn't really call him a little
[ __ ] cuz he was at a hot pepper eating
contest
and that's when he ate that no I mean
his his his friends his colleagues yeah
because they're all spicy people Khali's
will call you a [ __ ] for no reason
here's your not alright so here that
this contest in New York and he started
having these intense headaches and he
started dry heaving after eating that
pepper that sounds normal and then it
turned out that so he was sent to the ER
it was just like so dramatic you're not
supposed to have a [ __ ]
all-you-can-eat buffet with a Carolina
Reaper like the challenge is just eat
one not can you [ __ ] eat a whole like
stuff your stomach with Carolina Reaper
I don't even think you're supposed to
even have the challenge like I think
usually the actual use is when they're
doing like a big-ass dinger like
crawfish or chili like you put maybe two
of those things in there you just want
yeah one yeah so then he got a CT scan
and it ruled out a blood clot or
bleeding
and what I just picture like the CT scan
and they see it and it's just like
flames what it did show though was that
he had the narrowing of one of his
arteries and for other blood vessels
that supply the brain so she had this
narrowing happen so this is it this is
normal and this is brain exploded
literally got dumber yeah worth it he
was diagnosed with our CVS which is
reversible cerebral vasoconstriction
syndrome and so usually it's
characterized by like an intense
thunderclap headache due to the
constriction of thunderclap yeah damn
usually it's resolved within a few days
or weeks and that's a long time but at
least is resolved is let's give it a
couple days or months or weeks yeah
that's the baby come on dog [ __ ]
yeah yeah and then something they're
saying that our CVS can even be
triggered by extreme emotions like after
finding out some someone close to your
diet or something you can you can get
that it's that moment in the movie when
it's raining and you get to your knees
and you go wow I like that exactly and
then usually sleep by it after because I
got the are CBS CS k yeah the CBS CBS
pharmacies yes PCT yeah then uh so
they're safer this guy's case they can't
really pinpoint exactly whether it was
the Carolina Reapers fault
or if it was what they're saying I
probably was the reaction to the pepper
that caused that so not the pepper
itself with the bodily reaction that
caused the that's okay or he has an
agonized girlfriend doesn't shut up oh
yeah that causes out a lot too wow
that's so on Angie can you imagine the
hospital like going through so many
weird things like if every single
hospital can tell us what is the
weirdest [ __ ] you've seen the [ __ ]
jam jargon they're pulling it out of a
[ __ ] man
whole everyday yeah it's like Oh a spot
weird that's normally majority of ER
[ __ ] yeah though the other day the guy
had paint donuts up his [ __ ] or
whatever you know within like wow that's
gentle what a wasted crispy creamy stuff
did yeah he stuffed the whole box of
doughnuts Oh like in the box with the
box yeah that pink box that they all use
you know or I don't know that's great
branding there so probably used to it
like oh this guy he came in because he
ate too many ghost peppers oh not
another one
yeah how many of it is like people doing
stupid [ __ ] and going to the hospital
versus people that really need to be
there because they're like sick remember
we heard the guy that put a fish in his
butt and the fish started eating him
from the inside out
oh yeah you reported it uh-huh
remember when steve-o put a [ __ ] or yeah
he put a racecar does Chris Pontius
oh never mind what do you think put a
little [ __ ] race Carnot's but they
took x-ray wow that was amazing
alright for our last story here there
was there was these metal fans so
they're fans of the music like the metal
oh I like old-school fans let me see I
was like those are dope ya know people
that are fanatics of the music given
metal music so they were mistaken for a
suicide pact members and so they had a
police just storm in and try to rescue
them and try to rescue the children that
were with them and apparently someone
called in saying like I think these
people are gonna commit suicide they
were camping by the way the people here
they're saying hey because like they
have kool-aid
it's like a bunch of [ __ ] it was mainly
because they were dressed in black and
the kids had like pink team being on
their face this is what they look like
so we thought that they were welcome
it's
this guy was deleted how do you assume
they're gonna commit suicide but they
were bloody large yeah would have been
like they're going to a KISS concert
yeah but they were camping this way so
then I guess that's one people thought
some other [ __ ] one white lady thought
oh it's a white lady old lady's all over
the world though do jump to conclusions
like a [ __ ] like they get scared
from watching news and [ __ ] and then
like they that's something crazy you
gotta have on rain boots that's how you
kill yourself so the blood doesn't get
anywhere yeah so they were camping on
this little island thing and then they
left their car on shore and so
apparently when the police showed up
they broke into the car looking for a
suicide note because they thought Verdi
did it I think they were they were about
to do it but wait why would they look
for the note person sitting stopping
these are important the note is
important it's like a warrant to stop
yeah yeah and then so the people here
they're just saying like well you know
the police did a great job rescuing us
but we just didn't need rescuing
dude Wow don't judge a book by it's
cover lady that's pretty much the lesson
here yeah but I mean shout-out to them
because in America you walk past a chick
getting punched in the face and you just
keep walking
you don't call anybody
she tried we're in America you call for
like help and then they come and shoot
all the guys but they shoot up all the
guys are trying to rescue man that's all
sad maybe she moved to Scotland oh I
feel like man I don't know if I'm gonna
be that I wonder if I'm that type of
person that would call [ __ ] in because
we're American yeah you know I feel like
I should be though like if some [ __ ]
goes down I should be like eh I got a
call this in
well we might when we're like 50 yeah my
mom knows though when we're living in
that hammer house she's like she's like
in the kitchen oh you could see your
neighbor oh that Megan a burka see you
oh no you kind of close the breaker
why people call the police so she even
she know that like white people see
something that they don't like they're
gonna call the police on you
[Music]